all righty everyone my name is edward
tunisian i'm one of the board of
directors of internet infidels and i'm
on their kiosk editorial review
committee as well and i have a library
piece on the origin of evil and today
i'm going to be interviewing the
legendary bill gatey thank you for being
on the show sir
yeah no problem all right
before going to the interview questions
did you want to tell us a little bit
about yourself and your biography
well uh yeah there's not much to tell or
maybe there's too much to tell i don't
know which way you want to look at it
uh yeah i've uh
ran into trouble because i got into
politics
and uh to make a long story short i
ended up in uh fris as many people know
out there
and uh
after i got out i left all that [ __ ]
behind uh you know
my recommendation to anyone out there
never get into politics gotcha
all righty and that was my problem
that's all right all righty
okay so to go into the first question
for today
um what is your rope hypothesis and what
are some of the problems with the
standard model of light like the wave
packet
yeah i guess we gotta start at the
beginning and that's a big long
introduction because sure
if you look at mathematical physics
today right just any branch whether it's
general relativity quantum mechanics
string theory or any
even the dissidents uh people like the
electric universe and uh what is it the
uh john
chapter chapel chappelle society you
know these people
they have irrational explanations
for uh
almost any physical phenomena almost any
physical interpretation is irrational
today
why is it irrational um it starts i
think uh like three centuries ago fourth
century you know and i'm going to cover
it year by year okay by the way sounds
good
but uh if you go back um what happened
in the 17th century known as the 17th
century
so-called scientific revolution
they abandoned the greeks
and what they did they moved on to
something new which was hey do
experiments
measure get some equations
and then we will
be able to figure out how this universe
works
the problem with that was that the how
had to do with descriptions and not with
a why with the causes with what
what is the physical interpretation for
how the universe actually works meaning
what is making it do all these things
and the issue here is that with
experiments you are not able to
determine something which is invisible
and intangible
if we go to the lab
you can do some you can measure whatever
is visible intangible you cannot measure
that which is not
and the problem here is that mother
nature runs her world or father universe
who god the devil whoever you want to
pray to right
they run the unit they run the universe
with invisible intangible mediators
and so we're not going to be able to
discover them through
experiments
and all you can do with measurements is
measurement what is seeable and
touchable
you cannot
measure that which is not seeable and
touchable and what they did uh
really since day one and uh
you know they always used particles as
a
simulator for all these things they said
it's done with particles and then in the
17th century they came up with
waves uh robert hook was the guy who
really came up with waves he wrote his
book micrographia in 1665
and that's when the wave theory started
uh
handled later on a little later by uh
christian huygens from a dutch guy
okay so they came up with a wave theory
but see both the waves and the particles
are one-way mechanisms yeah
one way they come out of something and
go
okay well the problem with that is that
you can simulate push
but you cannot simulate pull
yeah and so what's missing today in all
of mathematical physics what is missing
today in the dissonance
is pull we do not have the force of pull
we do not have a mechanism for the force
of pull
and so if you want to pull you have to
have an extended entity
okay
and if you want to pull down a donkey
you don't throw stones at it you have to
tie a rope around its neck and then you
can pull
you know so that's if you're going to
give a physical interpretation for
action at a distance phenomena such as
entanglement such as um gravity
okay
you're gonna need to put some mediator
that pulls
and that's where we're that's where
mathematical physics is lacking and the
reason it's lacking we go back to the
17th century it's that they said we're
going to figure all this out by doing
equations measuring and doing
experiments
and here we are 400 300 400 years later
and what we have is a particle can be at
two places at once a zero dimensional
singularity is known as a black hole and
that pulls on a star which is billions
of miles away and we and we have big
bang which is the creation of space and
matter so what existed before well
that's an unscientific question yeah and
so yes they give you the run around and
you say what have i learned what do i
understand about the universe yeah
when you push put all these people
against the wall they say well that's
philosophy anyways yeah go to the
philosopher go to the other side of
campus and ask the philosophers of
science you go there
you take the trouble you go there and
they say oh we get our cues from the
mathematical businesses by the way you
know so it's a runner to go back yeah
yeah
okay but uh james maxwell essentially
established that
light has some kind of vibration some
kind of wave
it's some kind of weight phenomena and
he got that first from faraday and even
before that from um french guy um what's
his name
uh
augustine fresnel okay okay augustine
frannel he essentially
uh came up with this
uh wave
he developed the wave theory and from
there on for the 19th century it was all
wave theory james maxwell put some
equations to describe all that and today
we have that description we have some
description that
light is some sort of wave but when you
look at the wave of mathematical physics
what you find are vectors
you know
all those things that are moving there
are uh they they're little arrows and
you say well what are those little
arrows well those are vectors what is a
vector magnitude and direction
so that's what's moving just magnitude
under what's magnitude a number so you
have the number five pointed in some
direction it's moving
in other words again it's a mathematical
description that's what you're staring
at but they had to put something in
front of your eyes to say you're staring
at a wave okay uh what is that wave it's
just a bunch of numbers what's the field
what's a numbers what's a magnetic field
a bunch of numbers what's an electric
field a bunch of numbers a gravitational
field bunch of numbers yeah that's all
we have our description mathematics can
only describe
now what i say what happens if we
replace the famous wave with a rope
okay now here's a two-strand rope okay
and i'm saying that assuming my two
fists are atoms right okay
i'm saying that this rope
if it torques the torsion on a rope
is what light is it's not a flow of
particles it's not the waving up and
down or in any way of a transverse wave
which is a bunch of vectors no it's a
physical rope that binds any two atoms
that's my starting that's my assumption
so once we have this assumption at least
now we have a physical entity right that
uh
can produce action at a distance
but what's the issue here the issue here
is first we're talking about a physical
interpretation
second we're not saying look i'm going
to give you a bunch of math and equation
no we don't care about that we're saying
how does mother nature do it in real
life she she never went to school she
doesn't know what math is yeah we
embedded these relations okay
you want to know how she runs her
universe and and if she has planets like
the earth and the sun
she she works with objects she doesn't
work with equations so you have to
explain why does the earth fly out of
the solar system how does an atom affect
another one at a distance etc etc etc
and for that you need physical objects
and so we get rid of all the math we get
rid of all the equations we don't need
them because we're not going to be
describing not because they're
not useful but
we're not going to be describing we want
to explain
in order to explain in order to get to a
physical interpretation i need to put
objects so i put an object i'm saying
light is some sort of
entity elongated entity and i'm saying
if we simulate it with something that
looks like a rope a two strand twine
thread a pair of threads
then you can imagine torsion
along this thread this twine thread this
rope as i call it
and
one of the things you realize that
torsion is the fastest type of wave
imaginable
yeah true if you look if you look at
transverse waves if you look at
longitudinal waves
you know the the
torsion wave at least it leaves them
both you know biting the dust
so so i'm saying look an atom expands
and contracts as mr boar niels bohr
discovered his quantum jump
expands and contracts then if we assume
that the atom is a ball
not a little little tiny bead circling a
nucleus but an actual membrane a balloon
that and
encapsulates something inside we don't
we don't have to go into any detail
there but it encapsulates something
inside well you can imagine this
membrane expanding and contracting
torquing the rope while it does so and
sending that signal to another atom down
the road
meanwhile all atoms are interconnected
physically interconnected now you can
explain action at a distance the only
issue we have to resolve now
is where we should have started in the
first place and that's that physics
cannot be done without an object the
problem is that for uh we've always
misdefined the word object everybody if
you look it up in the dictionary if you
ask anyone people say well an object
what i can see and touch because that's
our experi everyday experience we see
touching okay this uh i can touch this
so this is an option i can touch the
table it's an object i can touch the
wall it's an object yeah but that's not
what it is for the purposes of physics
because there are objects we cannot see
or touch and they are still objects we
cannot see the air
and you say was the ear and object it
sounds kind of
weird in ordinary speech but it has to
be treated that way because air is made
out of atoms and i can't i'm touching an
atom here and i can't see or touch it
but there's something there you know we
call it an atom uh we work with that we
say there's a bunch of atoms here that
i'm breathing something's going into my
nose i can't see it
so is is that not a thing
i can't see the chair that's on the
other side of the planet in china
is that chair the guy that's sitting on
that chair is that not is that chair not
an object yeah yeah so so we have you
can't use the c touch criteria which is
what's used in ordinary speech for
physics you have to use that which has
shape
yep when you define it that way all
objects in the universe share one common
property and that is shape they all have
to have shape there's not a single
object anyone can imagine that does not
have shape
so what does that mean that means that
this rope is an object because it has
shape
not because you can see or touch it so
when people say why can't i see the rope
why can't i touch the rope well now you
have an answer the first hand there's
more than one answers for that but now
you have your first answer you have the
wrong definition an object is not that
which you can see in touch an object is
that which has shape the rope meets that
uh definition okay and so you know
that's where that's our starting point
that's our assumption and from there
we're going to build the rope model of
light and gravity primarily
including magnetism electricity and the
workings of the atom sweet righty thank
you my introduction long-winded but i
had to do hey no no that's all good yeah
so people can get familiar with your
ideas and stuff that's good alrighty so
going on for our second question um how
do maniks attract
okay that's uh
uh you know sometimes uh they say a
picture is worth a thousand words a
movie is worth a million words
unfortunately i didn't know what
question you were going to ask me in
advance so
i could have prepared some props i do
have videos on this but let me just see
if i can explain it the best
way possible here you have two magnets
okay gotcha uh those two little
dark things they're magnets and you can
see you know that they stick to each
other okay
typical magnet okay so the question is
again we can't see or touch what's in
between them
the second thing we notice is that
when i put them close to each other
nothing is pushing on my hands from the
outside
i'm being drunk from the inside i feel
the pull from the inside yeah
so this is some kind of pull
it's not a push mechanic some people
want to do it with particles
and it's not i don't feel anything
pushing my hands i feel already drawn
yeah yeah
and i'll give you another analogy which
uh falls in here
okay stretch out your hands you know
and
you know nothing is pushing on my arms
but i feel them like gravity is pulling
them from below yeah yeah yeah gravity
is a pull mechanic we always talk about
the pull of gravity but then they
simulate it with particles which can
only push
so we have a contradiction so we have to
face the first thing and that's that
this is some kind of pull
okay
this is some kind of the attraction
yeah that makes sense obviously if you
have a different
polarities they
push each other away but i mean the
attraction is some kind of pull because
i can feel it pulling from the inside
but as you can see you cannot see
there's nothing there you know i don't
smell it other than the air you know i
could do this in space it would work
also and the question is there's nothing
there i can see or touch
so we have to forget first of all about
see and touch yeah yeah okay so now we
have to discover what the mechanism is
and uh you've seen the standard um iron
filings
uh spread around magnets
and there's two type again pictures
worth a thousand words all i can do is
simulate it with my hands now yeah
that's all good
if if i want to push these two hands
apart you know imagine they're swinging
like um two rollers moving in the other
in opposite directions or maybe the um
the paddle wheels of two uh river boats
okay you know the riverboat has these
big paddles imagine these paddles moving
in opposite direction so they hit each
other and push each you know tend to
push each other away
what happens if they're going in the
same direction
well as one comes up the other one comes
down they latch on to each other and
that's where you have the pull mechanism
okay so i'm saying that when you have
two magnets like these that attract each
other what you're having is something
that's moving which we call the magnetic
field
something is moving in that field james
maxwell said in that region there is
matter in
motion
he said it and we forgot about that but
there's matter in motion some exotic
matter that is in motion okay so you
have this one coming up this one coming
down
each other you have pull what happens
when you turn it 180 degrees around like
north to south pole now you have the
opposite effect now you see why they
push each other away
so we have a mechanism of attraction and
repulsion
the next question is then what are the
what's in there what's in that invisible
area and what i'm saying is
it originates in the magnet we all i
think we'll agree on that
whatever it is it originates in the
magnet you can't have a field a magnetic
field without the magnet you got to
bring the magnet together
and so if we had the eyes of god and we
could see and touch in that region i
think what we would see is a bunch of
threads
moving in one direction the other one
moving in the opposite direction for
attraction and both
both sides moving in opposite directions
the threads countless threads pushing
each other away
what are those threats the threads that
come out of the rope what i'm saying
mother nature or father universe the
devil whoever
what they do the way they run this uh
world especially the in the magnets
right is you have you know you have all
these domains in a magnet when they are
aligned that's when you have attraction
or repulsion if you don't have a malign
all you have is a piece of iron okay
that's it but when they're aligned we
call it a magnet and why are they
aligned what do we mean by that i'm
saying that we have rows
of atoms
really molecules but it's easier to
conceptualize this with atoms imagine
hydrogen atoms right and they're all
magnetized what do we mean by that
they're all aligned they're all merged
together they all move
simultaneously what's moving what's
scrolling around
the threads that make up the the um uh
electron shell the electron brain and
also the ropes that interconnect them so
if you have these threads moving around
countless threads we can explain the
so-called lines of force that mr faraday
noticed in 1830s awesome
that's that's essentially in a nutshell
again a picture is worth a thousand
words
a million if i could show you the movie
and say oh i see what he's talking about
yeah awesome yeah yeah and for everyone
uh that you can change
go into uh bill gate he has a youtube
channel and he has a video on that so
you guys guys can check that out for
further details
yeah i have several videos on magnetism
sweet alrighty and then uh for our last
question this is the one i'm really
interested in um could you tell us about
your life as a spy back in the day
because i remember
when you were like on fox news and
everything and i was like dang
yeah with some great area great days you
know uh in my youth i mean i'm 69 now
but this was when i was in my 30s you
know 30 years ago
but yeah first of all it's uh you know
you're born with or not born but you're
raised with some ideals or you grow into
them and you make your own ideas about
the world and so i had these ideals and
uh you know i entered the communist
party at the time
and because of that you know when i came
to the states i decided to
use that my position in uh
in these companies to try to help the
west the eastern world in other words
the communist world because that's the
ideal you come with okay
and so what happens after a while you
you know it takes time but uh you
finally realize that it's not worth it
that something's wrong in your reasoning
but until then you know what we did was
you know we took uh material and uh we
gave it to the eastern bloc at the time
during the cold war okay and just that i
got to a lot of trouble uh turned myself
in by the way i turned myself in to the
cia first
okay
i uh
they put me in contact with the fbi and
they we worked for about two years
and uh you know just trying to
infiltrate the cuban in this case it was
the cuban um intelligence service uh
they're what it's called the ministry of
the interior
and you know they got some names that
sort of thing and uh what happened was
in between we had these companies amd
and intel they
uh figured out what we were doing more
or less uh yeah i cleaned their hands
off of me and i had them for my life
oh man
they caught up with me uh
we agreed uh i plea bargained with them
and uh they gave me a very lenient
service sentence
and after my time was done you know i
got out of that but even before that i
had lost my ideals completely and today
all i can recommend to people who
get into politics you know you have
people from the right people from the
left they have their ideals and what
they should how the world should be run
if you can't do anything about it forget
it just turn your tv off
okay yeah yeah that's the safest way you
know it's very exciting when you're in
there but you know what these
governments do they sacrifice sometimes
upon here upon there because uh at some
point maybe it's not convenient for them
anymore and those decisions are taken by
the heads of the intelligence services
and you know you got a person out there
who's doing something and they say well
turn this guy in because for whatever
reason and the guy may not even know it
but they turn them in they say well he's
a small pond tournament you know they do
this stuff and so
when they turn one guy over or when one
guy
you know comes out of a country and
leaves and goes to work for the other
country that guy knows a lot of spies
and he said oh by the way you know this
guy's a spy over there and this has
another and they turn spies in they go
after these guys in some countries they
execute them
gotcha gotcha i mean a lot of these so
spying is a bad business never get into
spine and also never get into politics
yeah
it's much more grueling than the james
bond films it's not as exciting well you
have your excitement but then you have
your danger but more so on the danger
side i guess
is all the girls that they offer you
[Laughter]
see
james bond took all this these beautiful
girls and you know you go around without
you just gotta do your work you know by
the time
you're on your own
like dang it that's the only reason i
joined
yeah and they say you'll see them in spy
heaven
yeah yeah
oh man
oh well yeah well uh thank you for
answering all those questions and then
um
so and then so uh and then one more
thing um so there's a movie out there
called the crazy chat and that's
basically about your life as a spy and
stuff correct yeah
pretty much it covers uh most of what i
did okay
sweet and is that on your uh your
youtube channel by chance
i'm sorry is that on your youtube
channel
the only place that i can find i don't
even have a movie uh i watched so a
couple times but it's on uh the amazon
uh what is it uh prime amazon prime okay
okay so people can check it out they're
awesome yeah yeah yeah absolutely
awesome all righty well thank you for
answering all these questions sir and
then by the time